c'est un procès qui a passionné le
nouveau brunswick faut dire que tous les
éléments sont réunis un milliardaire
sauvagement assassiné dans son bureau
son fils accusés est trouvé coupable du
meurtre dans un premier procès devant
jury deuxième procès a lieu et cette
fois un jugement jury trouve l'accusé
non coupable du meurtre de son père
c'est la paire or l'inde du nom de
dennis green le fils trouvé non coupable
du meurtre de son père rup ture hollande
qui a fait fortune entre autres avec la
bière mooseheads dans les maritimes donc
c'est une famille extrêmement connue
dans les maritimes
deborah des tomassi cette avocate
criminaliste elle est avec moi en studio
pour essayer de nous faire comprendre ce
qui avait pu se passer parce que
denilson donc le fils de rupture ornent
la victime visite son père le jour du
meurtre il est la dernière personne à le
voir vivant il a quatre petites
gouttelettes de sang sur son veston sur
ses vestes qui correspondent à l'adn de
son père comment ne plus petits pas être
coupable du meurtre mais il ya plusieurs
éléments qui ont été analysées par le
jeu je vous dis c'est un jugement qui
est extrêmement long qui décortique à
peu près tout ce que puis avoir comme
preuve dans le dossier
en gros c'est que la poursuite sa
théorie c est ça ne pouvait être que lui
l'opportunité faisais que c'était le
seul possible et cdh avec lui le fils
avait des dettes en plus avec son père
oui c'est ça c'est un peu l'histoire des
lésés cette famille multimilliardaire
des maritimes en fait je pense que l'une
des plus riches le fisc lui des
problèmes financiers
divorces sont pas relus près de l'argent
le père aulas a une maîtresse lui aimé
qu'l semble mécontent de la situation et
le soir des événements de juillet 2011
se présente voir son père à trois
reprises
la théorie de la poursuite c'est qu'il
allait y aller une première fois pour
lui parler
une deuxième fois pour lui demander de
l'argent qui semble-t-il selon la
théorie la poursuite lui ont été refusés
et de revenus une troisième fois pour
finalement être sous une rage
incompréhensible au dessus et son père
on parle quand même de 45 coups au
niveau du crâne donc et c'est pas le 45e
coup qui a tué mon père donc on parle
d'un crime passionnel extrêmement
violent par contre lorsqu'on commence à
regarder la preuve est qu'on lit le
jugement
de monsieur marcel de justin c'est
qu'est ce qu'on constate c'est que il y
avait tellement de sang sur la scène de
crime qu'il est impossible pour
l'assaillant d'avoir que trois bouts et
que 3 à 4 gouttelettes de 3 mm charles
que ses vestons l'or ont été nettoyés
par un nettoyeur est que les deux
nettoyeurs les deux personnes ont été
interrogées
ils disent nous nous avons analysé le
veston en question et il n'y avait rien
d'alarmant
alors ça c'est une des choses il ya
également le fait qu'on découvre
seulement peu de temps avant un policier
peu de temps avant son témoignage à
l'enquêté préliminaire dont on parle
très longtemps dans le temps vous
réalisez que ya peut-être une faute de
preuves une trace de pieds et de la tête
et qu'on constate que c'est pas ça ne
peut pas être consistant avec les pieds
de son fils alors ils ont plein de
choses la toque c'est la notion de doute
raisonnable à ce moment c'est ça qui
entrent en ligne de compte pour
acquitter
oui le doute raisonnable mais c'est
toujours un peu complexe d'expliquer le
doute raisonnable c'est pas l'absolu
mais c'est pas loin c'est pas peut-être
c'est en et c'est difficile à expliquer
mais en même temps ces cd qu'on a un
doute il
il a commis on le juge doit la quitter
et qui a d'autres qui suivent skis comme
quant au jay simpson essaye le gall dans
son fameux procès puis que ça marche pas
il est peut-être doute raisonnable qui
s'instaure dans l'exacte est ma fille
dans ce cas ci ça a été vraiment un
dossier de doute raisonnable à ce qu'il
y avait deux versions possibles
la version d' à poursuivre la version la
défense puis dans ce que 6 des
naissances
le fils a témoigné donc le juge n'a pas
le choix lui de prendre les jugements de
la cour suprême dans air compte wdc le
juge banque liquide y voici
si je crois l'accusé je crois la preuve
qui est amenée mal par la défense je
doit la quitter
parce que le juge a dit il ya des
faiblesses dans des voyages de l'accusé
il ya beaucoup d'éléments pour
l'impliquer mais je peux pas accepter la
version de la couronne telle qu'elle est
présentée donc sans doute raisonnable
en même temps madame des thomas six mois
je comprends pas y'a un jury il ya
quelques années donc douze paires de
tennis en ligne qui les ont trouvés
coupables avec la même preuve présentée
devant eu comment ça se fait que
julie le trouve coupable puis un juge le
trouve non quoi ce qui est difficile
avec un jury c'est qu'on n'a pas accès à
leur délibéré mais c'est à dire
lorsqu'ils sont dans leurs champs de
délibéré ce qui se décide là on n'aura
jamais accès à ça alors que le juge les
a produites 146 pages la décision ou
est-ce qu'il décortique et qu'il
explique tout il n'y a pas une roche qui
a été soulevé à savoir pourquoi lui
arrive à la conclusion en droit et en
fait qu'il est impossible pour lui de
conclure hors de tout doute raisonnable
que de donner 120 est coupable smart ne
sont pas mes skis et une dynamique qui
peut s'installer parce que le jury c'est
des monsieur madame tout le monde des
citoyens ordinaires qui doit faire leur
travail de jury de jurer pardon le ils
n'ont pas la même vision finalement que
le jugeons pas le même bagage ou
d'expérience que le juge non plus alors
comment un jury fonctionne c'est dire
qu'il est la dynamique qui peut
s'installer à l'intérieur d'un jury dans
un procès comme celui de monsieur rome
écoutez prenez deux personnes qui se
connaissent pas qui peuvent peut-être
avoir de connaissances en commun saint
john fait une petite région
mettez les ensembles confiner les
insectes à une chambre mais qui ont leur
dit vous pouvez pas sortir tant donné à
une décision unanime
tout est possible à mettet douze
personnes que vous connaissez pas mais
l'ensemble tout est possible et il ya
des dynamiques qui vont s'installer
c'est certain je sais pas si en fait
j'imagine que la stratégie de la défense
était gagnant dans ce que si elle au
deuxième procès mais c'est clair qu'ils
ont pas nécessairement fait exactement
la même chose parce que la masse a pas
fonctionné la première fois donc et ils
ont eu l'avantagé d'avoir en plus des jo
les gens qui ont témoigné donc elle
avait accès à leurs témoignages tant
qu'ils ont pu travailler autour de
veiller au taux de 100 ans a pour
fonction première fois qu'est ce que je
peux faire la de la défendre de toute
évidence à perdre son pays qu un procès
devant juge et jury la première fois a
gagné son pari d'une certaine façon
parce que c'est un juge qui a mené le
deuxième procès qui décide si c'est
devant juge et jury ou devant juge seul
dans les accusations de meurtre c'est
absolument toujours devant juge et jury
et si une décision à l'effet qu'on va
aller devant juge seul
ça doit être de consentement des deux
parties donc les la couronne en principe
a consenti à ce que ce soit un juge seul
qui entendent le deuxième procès dans ce
cas aussi il s'appelle pour des raisons
aussi parce qu'il ya beaucoup de preuves
techniques maquis qui peut équiper 10 et
l'asim autorisé étourdir les jurés des
fois on n'écoute plus ou bien on est
piqué parce que lui des preuves vidéo il
ya des preuves de tours cellulaires de
gps de caméras vidéo datée de l'adn ce
pour cinq ans à comprendre
nécessairement pour parce qu'on a de la
veine de quelqu'un sur soi qu'on le
suivant je peux avoir votre adn sur moi
parce que j'ai passé à côté de vous un
peu plus tôt non mais bossut encore vous
ai pas dit je vous dirai pas ça mais et
dernière question les avocats qui
choisit les membres du jury parce que là
on voit des soins au palais de justice
des files de gens qui sont qui a qui ont
vraiment devenir devenir juré il doit y
avoir une sélection qui sait les avocats
doivent chercher un type particulier de
jury et qu'il ya toutes sortes de
théories sockeel genre de personne
serait comme le plus et on analyse un
peu notre dossier on dimanche quel genre
de personne à ce que je veux un
ingénieur parce qu il pense de telle
façon ce que je veux une mère de famille
parce que je veux quelqu'un essentielle
que vous défendez quelqu'un vous voulez
injures et sympathique à votre client
mais tout dépend du type de cause qu'on
a
qu'est ce que c'est qu'être cet or la
10ème à quel type de meurtre si c'est un
meurtre c'est une agression sexuelle
on va chercher ce que nous on pense que
c'est ses hôtes erika quelque part quel
type de personne serait justement plus à
l'aise avec avec nos clients et pour
choisir un juré il faut le consentement
de l'avocat de quoi non un juriste
automatique pour un meurtre mais
lorsqu'elle et les jus les candidats
défilent alors que quelques petites
questions qui leur sont posées
dépendamment acquis et le taux la
poursuite peut dire qu'il est satisfait
du candidat la défense plaide qu'il
l'est pas donc la personne est exclue
mon un nombre précis d'exclusion c'est
pour l'unité et la saveur d'un côté
comme de l'autre
et quand les deux parties sont
satisfaits la personne devient candidat
jury elle devient donc elle est
assermenté à partir de ce moment là de
rendre justice aux meilleurs de la faire
son travail des jurés est ce que vous
savez si ça peut aller en appel cette
décision s'ils s'appellent en a pas
c'est la poursuite qui va décider s'il
peut être une chose qu'ils ont 30 jojo
dès qu'ils ont un énorme travail à faire
c'est vraiment j'ai passé l'après-midi à
lire le jugement c'est vraiment
extrêmement étoffé
comme je vous dis y'a pas une roche que
pau a été tourné pour analyser tous et
chacun des éléments de monsieur le juge
à marseille en a fait tout un travail ça
c'est que la situation au jugement des
tomates et merci